not everyone is able to spend their
Christmas with loved ones
if it wasn't for pubs cafes and
Community groups opening their doors
thousands would spend it alone I would
be back in Canary Wharf right now and
I'd probably be alone in my little flat
it's just I don't know it's such a gift
it really is like in this moment I
wasn't sure I felt brave enough and I
was thinking of all reasons not to call
but the Highlight is being so welcome I
think it's just such a fantastic
opportunity for so many different people
to come together and people that I
wouldn't ordinarily have interacted with
or met otherwise the number of people
relying on the generosity of others is
on the rise this Pub in Wimbledon was
packed offering free food friendship and
warmth for those in need I just think
it's one of those things that you know
if you sit in the house on your own
you're going to get a lot of people do
we've got nowhere to go for it for a lot
of different reasons and it's much
better for our mental health and all the
rest if we come out and we mix other
people and have a bit of a laugh and
what we're trying to do really is break
down that kind of uh stigma where if
you're on you're not gonna be ashamed of
anyone can end up lonely over Christmas
for a whole host of reasons but
admitting isolation can be pretty scary
and with the cost of living crisis
taking its grip across the country many
won't just be lonely this Christmas
they'll be cold and hungry too is it
morning yeah this community group in
Birmingham is one of many set up across
the country offering a safe place on
Christmas Day and they say this year has
been busier than ever we've had to work
with other Charities to signpost people
elsewhere because we haven't been able
to meet the demands so the demand is
outstriping the event the ability that
we've got to provide on such large
numbers so we've worked with partner
organizations so that we can make sure
people get the help and support that
they need and after a difficult year
dominated by news of financial pressure
it seems that more people than usual
relied on the kindness of strangers to
help see them through which is what
Christmas is all about
Shimon Freeman Powell Sky News